also a big convention is in town tonight
and more are on the schedule but
is delta posing a risk to what's ahead
thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez the magic trade
show is back for the first time in two
years
madison kimbrough spoke to convention
goers who admit
it is a little bit different this time
madison
yeah the magic fashion trade show is one
of the biggest attractions to take place
here at the las vegas convention center
and i spoke to several people that said
while it is different inside this year
it's great to have it back in action
we love coming here and there hasn't
been any for two years
this was the first one and we decided it
was worth getting on a plane
and coming and seeing connecting with
all of our vendors
and supporting the industry the magic is
back
at the las vegas convention center
monday the magic fashion trade show
known
as the most comprehensive fashion
marketplace in the u.s
arrived in vegas for a three-day stint
its first in two years
attendees say that the safety protocols
in place at the convention center
are on point making them feel
comfortable talking with groups of
people
and walking around in the crowd i felt
like everyone did a really good job
giving a little bit of distance everyone
had their face masks on
there were sanitation stations all
around
so i feel like all in all people just
like kind of respected
people's spaces and things like that
with the delta variant being a major
concern for travelers it leaves the
question of whether shows this fall will
get canceled
according to l-v-c-v-a there are no show
cancellations or postponements at this
time
rick diamond owner of a men's clothing
store in ohio
has been coming to the magic fashion
trade show since the 80s
and he says while he is pleased to see
it back in action things have changed
it's gone from here to the mandalay bay
and back and for
people like us it seemed to be a little
more active
back in the day just a little more
excitement
and now i feel a little more just about
business
now again the magic fashion trade show
will last until this wednesday august
11th and what's next on the books
we've got the international pizza expo
2021 that's going to be on august 17th
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now